[موسيقى]
التي أنشأناها الآن باسم AFAD
في جميع الحاويات
مفروشة بالكامل من الألف إلى الياء
نحن نبني من قطر
في حاوياتنا
جاؤوا بالمواد
اعمال صيانة الحاويات
بعد الفحوصات اللازمة
على استعداد لتقديمه لمواطنينا
آمل بعد إحضار الحاوية
مدينتنا لاستخدام شعبنا
سنفتحه في أعمال الصيانة لدينا هنا
حاليا في مستوى 30٪ من الدراسات
يستمر من الجانب
الأشياء الصغيرة التي يتعين علينا القيام بها
لدينا تغييرات
هذا مكان مبني على مساحة 67 فدان.
حاليا في الحاوية
المواطنون الذين تم وضعهم
743 جاهز للاستخدام
هناك حاويات بالإضافة إلى هذه
لدينا 15 حاوية للمدرسة ، 9 للمدرسة.
الخدمات الاجتماعية للأسرة
لدينا 4 حاويات للوزارة
أيضا للمستشفى
[موسيقى]
الأشياء الصغيرة التي يتعين علينا القيام بها
لدينا تغييرات
بطريقة أو بأخرى قبل العيد و
بعد العيد ومرة ​​أخرى خلال العيد
دون مقاطعة عملنا
جعل مواطنينا أكثر راحة في أسرع وقت ممكن
بسبب الظروف
نأمل أن نواصل عملنا